la république démocratique du congo n'en
a pas fini avec leur des virus les plus
mortelles au monde les autorités
congolaises ont confirmé les soupçons
sur l'apparition d'un nouveau foyer de
fièvre hémorragique ebola
après quatre décès suspect dans la
province de l'équateur
jusqu'à présent huit cas ont été
officiellement recensés depuis le 30 mai
dans la ville de banda qu'à environ 600
km au nord-est de la capitale congolaise
kinshasa le gouvernement assure avoir
envoyé sur place des 12 d'un vaccin
expérimental
quand vous le savez c'est une province
qui a déjà connu cette maladie et
jean-jacques réflexes ne sait qu'il faut
faire et ils ont déjà commencé
la riposte au niveau local de prière
commence déjà à maxine et le
nos compatriotes d'ela et à traiter les
gens qui sont
qu'ils soient atteints de cette maladie
les autorités congolaises ont sollicité
l'appui de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
car cette nouvelle épidémie descente
d'ebola vient s'ajouter à un autre foyer
de contagion dans l'est du pays où le
virus a tué plus de 2000 personnes
depuis août 2010 8
si aucun cas détectés d'ici le 25 juin
la fin de cette épidémie local sera
officiellement proclamée la république
démocratique du congo est habitué au
virus dangereux
le pays a déjà affronté 11 fois ebola
depuis sa découverte en 1976 déjà dans
la province de l'équateur
la rdc est également touché par la
pandémie de coronavirus qui a
officiellement fait près de 70 victimes
aux fins le gouvernement congolais lui
aussi contre une épidémie de rougeole
qui a tué plus de 6000 personnes depuis
le début 2019 dans le pays